تعد روسيا ببساطة في السوق العالمية
للغاز الطبيعي ولأوروبا لأن
وصلات خطوط الأنابيب
وديناميكيات السوق لشحن
الغاز الطبيعي عبر خطوط الأنابيب من روسيا القريبة قد
طورت على مدار الثلاثين عامًا الماضية اعتمادًا على
الإمداد الروسي للغاز الطبيعي
يختلف هذا الاعتماد من  أه من بلد
إلى بلد داخل أوروبا ولكن بشكل عام
أكثر من 40 في المائة
من الغاز الطبيعي الأوروبي يأتي اليوم من
روسيا وبالطبع مع الغزو الروسي
لأوكرانيا ،
هناك الآن حالة طارئة بعض الشيء
لأن 40 في المائة من الإمدادات
معرضة للخطر ومن الواضح أن  روسيا
مورد لا يُعتمد عليه للغاز الطبيعي
لذا
بعد سقوط الاتحاد السوفيتي
عام 1991 كان هناك جهد أمريكي
لإدماج
اقتصاد الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق
في الاقتصاد العالمي أه وكانت
الفكرة هنا أنه كلما كان أكثر
ارتباطًا  كانت روسيا
بالنسبة لبقية الاقتصاد العالمي
، كلما كان اللاعب الروسي أكثر مسؤولية ،
لذلك كانت الفكرة أن
تبدأ  أولاً مع الروابط
الاقتصادية وأن هذه الروابط ستنضج
بمرور الوقت وتتطور إلى
روابط سياسية وثيقة وأن هذه
هي الطريقة التي تقود الاقتصاد ،
كانت هذه هي الطريقة لدمج روسيا
في مجتمع الدول بعد
سقوط الاتحاد السوفيتي.
ثبت أنه
غير ناجح
بعد 30 عامًا
من سقوط الاتحاد السوفيتي ،
ما أثبته الغزو الروسي لأوكرانيا
هو أن تلك الثلاثين عامًا من
التكامل الاقتصادي لربط روسيا
ببقية العالم أثبتت أنها غير كافية ،
فقد أثبتت عدم كفاية
رادعًا للعدوان الروسي.  لسوء الحظ
اليوم
ما نراه يفعله
ما نراه يفعله العالم الغربي
هو محاولة الاسترخاء
أو فصل
روسيا عن الاقتصاد العالمي
وعكس إجراءات الثلاثين عامًا الماضية
بالطبع توفر روسيا لأوروبا 40 من
وارداتها من الغاز.  كل جزء من
السوق العالمية
أه لذا فليس من
السهل استبدال 40
من ديموقراطية أوروبية
وإه الذي يتم تغذيته اليوم من قبل روسيا ،
لا يمكنك عكس 30 عامًا
من علاقات التوريد التي تم بناؤها بين
روسيا وأوروبا في 30 يومًا أه لذا
سيستغرق الأمر وقتًا طويلاً
وبالطبع
سوق الغاز والنفط
بالفعل هادئ  ضيق مع الإنتاج
بالقرب من المستويات القصوى ، لذا
لن يكون السوق مصدر إغاثة فوري
للاحتياجات الأوروبية
، وحتى اليوم بعد 30 يومًا من
الغزو الروسي لأوكرانيا ، ترى
أوروبا لا تزال تستورد
الغاز الروسي ويمكننا أن نتوقع أن
يستمر ذلك لبعض الوقت  بينما أوروبا
تبحث عن بدائل لكن تلك
البدائل ليست سريعة